MARY POPPINS first movie instant Oscar
you just did that gonna skew your life
that you you well such a big deal Reese
hello but to be that famous suddenly it
hit you like a bulldozer yes it did yes
it did indeed no I think it sent me into
therapy and analysis mm-hmm all of that
because it's like oh wow what's going on
cuz what was a moment obviously you won
the Oscar for walk the line but what was
there a dice it was this you have a
moment in your life when you kind of
think oh I'm actually very famous now I
I remember I actually I was I was here
in England doing The Importance of Being
Earnest film and then Legally Blonde
came out in America and it made all this
money and I went back to America and my
whole life had changed oh there were
paparazzi waiting at the airport I had a
little baby I was completely terrified
hey but did anyone warn you know look
before you you can't know people don't
know who's gonna be him and you don't
know why you're the person that and you
don't keep a light you don't know it's
going to be a huge hit what did you know
Jennifer there's a famous picture of all
of you guys all the friends cast on a
plane I think you're being flown to the
babies oh yeah that's correct that's
what Jimmy burrows who was the director
a very fantastic infamous television
director took us to Vegas and took us to
dinner at Caesar's Palace it's very
fancy and you said told all of us to
basically said I want you guys to all
really look out for each other because
this is probably gonna go on for a long
time oh and he said so the most
important thing is to look out for each
other take care of each other and then
he gave us each a couple hundred dollars
and he said now go into this casino and
enjoy yourselves because it's the last
time that you'll have your anonymity
that's interest so we didn't know what
the heck that meant so we
but it really kind of was because once
that someone did sort of prep us but
then again when it happens you know so
you still think it's so weird yeah weird
so the bullets touring and trips yes I I
mean not that one should ever knock it
yes it's not part of being you know it's
a huge gift yeah but it is a lot of
obligation yeah it's strange when
someone comes up to you in the aisle of
a of a pharmacy and you're buying toilet
paper I know
oh I excuse me there's a fabulous story
about my my little Emma and she she was
about three and she was taken to the two
sacks of the local sacks that where they
had a huge display of cardboard cutouts
of Mary Poppins and everything I said oh
look there's mummy and and she suddenly
heard two ladies say isn't that sweet
that the bigger big Mary Poppins
[Applause]
[Music]
you